Good afternoon.
I'm Rafael Reif.
I'm MIT's president.
And I am delighted, and
it's a privilege for me,
to welcome you all to
this important event.
Let me just do a
microphone check.
Do you hear me way in the back?
Do you hear me all right?
Our subject today
is the report called
"Sexual Harassment of Women--
Climate, Culture,
and Consequences
in Academic Sciences,
Engineering, and Medicine."
As you would expect
from a Consensus
Report of the
National Academies,
it is a serious
piece of scholarship.
And we are fortunate
that its lead authors--
President of Wellesley
College, Paula Johnson,
and Institute Professor
Sheila Widnall of MIT--
are with us today.
I'd like to start by offering
a warm welcome to friends
and colleagues from
our academic neighbors,
including Wellesley
and Brandeis,
and a special welcome
to our guest speaker,
University Professor Anita Hill.
I also want to recognize--
[APPLAUSE]
My only job here today
was to introduce her.
I also want to recognize
Chancellor Cindy Barnhart,
Provost Marty Schmidt, Vice
President and General Counsel
Mark DiVincenzo, Vice President
for Human Resources Lorraine
Goffe, and then many
others here today
who have led the way, officially
and unofficially, over decades,
to make MIT a more equitable
and welcoming community
for everyone.
Thank you.
And by all means, keep going.
Today, I'm deeply encouraged.
Your attendance speaks
to the strong desire
to understand these
issues more fully
and to keep making progress.
In a moment, Sheila and Paula
will speak about their findings
and recommendations.
For now, I'll offer
just a few comments
on why these issues matter
so much right here at MIT.
Over the last year,
the Me Too movement
forced the whole country to
grasp that sexual harassment is
pervasive.
Like all of you, I was deeply
disturbed by the revelations
of misconduct elsewhere.
And I must believe it
also happens at MIT.
On this question, our community
is not an oasis of safety.
In fact, the National
Academies' report
makes these same points
about academic institutions
in general.
When it comes to
sexual harassment,
a community like ours presents
a particular set of risks--
a 24/7 environment that
brings together people
across a broad range of ages,
incomes, and backgrounds,
many of whom have
power over others--
the power to make being at
MIT miserable, power enough
to make or break a career.
The success of our community
is built on collaboration
and mutual respect.
Sexual harassment is
an act of aggression
that belittles,
unnerves, and controls.
It violates our
fundamental expectations
of respect and equality,
and it violates the humanity
of the person being harassed.
At MIT, fulfilling
our mission depends
on people of exceptional
talent performing
at the height of
their capacities
and working together to solve
the most challenging problems.
It's obvious that there can be
no room for sexual harassment
in that picture.
Last fall, I wrote
to the community
to express those
values and ideas.
And I also described our efforts
to fight sexual harassment
at MIT.
Let me offer a few
updates since then.
We have expanded rules
regarding consensual relations
among community members,
across lines of authority,
such as faculty and
graduate students.
We are assessing the
disciplinary process
for handling sexual
misconduct cases.
Marty, Cindy, Mark,
and Lorraine have
worked to develop
enhanced processes
for handling sexual harassment
complaints against staff
and faculty.
And these recommendations
are being vetted internally,
and I hope that we can start
to implement them soon.
Because a true solution
needs to include everyone,
we have also greatly
expanded training efforts.
Online, we started
with students.
And a week ago, Marty,
Cindy, and Lorraine
let us know that when we
expanded that online training
to include all paid
MIT faculty and staff,
the participation rate
was an outstanding 99.7%.
To the 9,300 faculty
and staff who
took the time to complete
this program, I thank you.
This is a tremendous expression
of this community's commitment
and values.
Finally, to make good
decisions, we need good data.
MindHandHeart is
already conducting
studies about the working
and learning environment
in various departments.
And next spring,
we will once again
conduct an in-depth survey
that will allow students
to convey how they
may have experienced
sexual misconduct at MIT.
I'm grateful to
everyone who has worked
so hard on these many fronts.
In the end, however,
the most important work
is up to all of us.
We need to actively
build a culture that
treats sexual
harassment, coercion,
and assault as out of bounds--
unthinkable for anyone of
any age in any context.
Getting the culture right
matters to us here on campus.
And it matters far
beyond campus too.
Because the students
we educate will go on
to launch, and lead, and
populate companies, labs,
agencies, institutions, and
governments around the globe.
And they will carry with
them the professional culture
they experience at MIT.
Finally, let me
state the obvious.
Most harassers are men.
As a result, the
men in our community
have a particular
responsibility and must
play a particularly
important role
in leading and driving the
necessary change in culture.
Every member of our
community is valuable.
And harm to one is harm to all.
As long as sexual
harassment and assault
persists in our
community, we fail
to live up to our
shared potential
and to fulfill our aspiration
to make a better world.
So I close with a challenge
that we each strive
to define what we can do
to invent a better MIT
community for those
who are here today
and for those who
follow us tomorrow.
And now, it is my great
honor to introduce someone
whose integrity and courage,
27 years ago, brought
sexual harassment to the center
of our national conversation.
In 1991, during the confirmation
hearings for US Supreme Court
nominee Clarence
Thomas, Anita Hill
testified that, as her
supervisor at the US Department
of Education and the Equal
Employment Opportunity
Commission, Clarence Thomas
had sexually harassed her.
For those of us who were
adults at that time,
Professor Hill's courage
in coming forward,
and the terrible disrespect she
endured during her testimony
and long afterward,
are unforgettable.
Until that moment,
sexual harassment
was a legal and academic term.
In fact, early
work on the subject
was done here at MIT by
our very own Mary Rowe.
But the concept was
not widely understood.
Today, we know that sexual
harassment is pervasive,
that it's wrong, and that
the responsibility to stop it
belongs to all of us.
For all that, we owe a
great debt of gratitude
to University
Professor Anita Hill.
A graduate of Yale Law School,
she's the author of two books,
including her autobiography,
Speaking Truth to Power.
Today, she serves as
the University Professor
of Social Policy, Law,
and Women's Gender,
and Sexuality
Studies at Brandeis.
And last fall, she was selected
by some leading figures
in Hollywood to chair
their new Commission
on Sexual Harassment
and Advancing Equality,
which aims to tackle the broad
culture of abuse and power
disparity in the
entertainment industry.
Professor Hill spent last
year as an MIT MLK scholar.
She continues as an
MIT research affiliate.
And we're very
proud to count her
as a member of our community.
Please join me in offering
a warm welcome to University
Professor Anita Hill.
[APPLAUSE]
Good evening.
Good afternoon.
Thank you.
Thank you, President Reif, for
that gracious introduction.
And thank all of
you for being here
to hear the report on this
incredibly impressive study
that I have already
begun relying on,
not only in my own work,
but in my teaching as well.
I'm really pleased
to be here at MIT.
I say I'm pleased to be back.
I was here last year.
But I'm especially pleased to
be here for today's program
on the National Academies
Consensus Study Report.
My first experience
with this study
came late in the year of 2016.
And that was at the
initial convening
of this really impressive
group of people
who have come together to
contribute to the work that
has resulted in the
publication that you're just
about to get a glimpse of.
I will tell you that
you will need more time,
and actually a lot more
time, because this report is,
I would say, the most
comprehensive report
on sexual harassment
in the research
and the recommendations that has
been published to this point.
And we are, of course, thrilled
that the co-chairs of the study
group, President Paula Johnson
of Wellesley University
and your own Sheila Widnall,
Institute Professor at MIT,
are here to present to us today.
This work actually set me--
the beginning of this work--
set me in good stead
for my year here
at MIT in the research
laboratory of electronics
as an MLK fellow.
And I have the pleasure of
partnering with Professor
Muriel Médard and her whole
laboratory, actually--
I felt like I was partnering
with the entire lab,
including our administrative
assistant, Molly Kruko,
Sampson Wilcox,
who created the art
for our series for this poster,
as well as a series of talks
that we presented to this
community about Title IX,
but more broadly about
gender and racial inclusion
in science, technology,
engineering, and medicine.
So we hosted this series, and
we called it the Gender Race
Imperative.
Because I realized that
gender inclusion was never
going to be complete unless we
include it in our thinking--
other identity factors as well.
And our talks were
focused really
on greater inclusion in STEM.
And really not just
the greater inclusion,
but how do we get there?
Not only talking
about the problem,
but how do we get to a solution.
Now, I will say--
and this could sound
immodest, but it's
not really immodest
because I didn't
give any of the lectures--
but the entire series
was quite excellent,
covering topics including law,
of course, the history of women
at MIT, which was a
lecture given by Bob Gray,
mentoring, given by Institute
Professor Leslie Kolodziejski,
and marginalization, and a
lecture given by Dr. Ellen
Hammond of Harvard.
There were many others as well.
And the tie-in to
today's program, I think,
will become much more obvious
as we go on for today.
But I do want you to know
that if you miss the lectures,
they are on our website.
And you can find them at
rle.mit.edu/anita-hill.
So no topic is more
important or timely
than the topic of sexual
harassment and gender
harassment throughout society.
We are fortunate that the
National Academy has taken up
the challenge of exploring
this extensive problem.
The contributions
that this volume makes
goes beyond science,
engineering, and medicine--
and beyond the
academic experience.
This consensus report
covers the issue,
whether it is in the workplace
as a workplace issue,
whether it's in
school, whether we're
talking about students or
people well into their career.
You will find
information that is
relevant to sexual harassment,
whether men are the victims,
women are the victims, or
whether non-binary individuals
are the victims.
So the range of this
work is really important.
But it's specifically
back to this setting.
In 2018 across the country
in universities and colleges
throughout, decisions
about the enforcement
of Title IX's protections are
being made, even as we meet.
It reminds me of
a statement that
was made by Senator Birch
Bayh when Title IX was first
enacted in 1972.
He admonished us that
Title IX was not a panacea.
But he said, "It is," and I will
quote, "an important first step
in the efforts to provide for
the women of America something
that is rightfully
theirs, an equal chance
to attend the schools
of their choice,
to develop the skills
they want, and to apply
those skills with the
knowledge that they will have
a fair chance to secure
jobs of their choice
with equal pay for equal work."
Now, what that also
means is that they
will be able to do
their jobs and attend
those schools in an environment
free from harassment.
But Title IX really
is just the start.
And the report brings that
out-- it's just the beginning.
This volume-- if Title
IX is the first step--
this volume is a
critical next step.
It provides guidance for
protecting against harassment.
It makes sure that women
in science, engineering,
and medicine are treated
fairly, from the school
of their choice, to equal pay
for equal work and in between.
By eliminating harassment,
women, men, and all individuals
have a better chance
of achieving equality.
Viewing harassment
as a systemic problem
is one of the greatest
contributions of this volume.
And there are many,
many more that I
won't get into, because that's
what our presenters are here
to do.
But I will say to all of
you who are here today,
whatever your
particular focus is,
whatever your particular
interest in the subject is--
whether it's
workplace harassment,
harassment in the academy,
harassment on the streets--
this volume has
recommendations, it has science,
and it also gives us
comfort in knowing
that change is possible.
And so with that, I will
turn the podium over
to Professor Widnall for a
presentation on the volume.
[APPLAUSE]
Let me check that the
microphone is working.
Can you hear me way
in the back row?
OK, good.
OK, before I start, I
would like to introduce
two people that are here.
Our study director, Frazier
Benya, can you raise your hand?
She flew all the way
up from Washington, DC.
She was the person who kept
us in track on our report.
We couldn't have
done it without her.
And then Kate Clancy, who
is from the University
of Illinois, and she was
a member of our committee.
And she is spending
this year at MIT.
So we're delighted to see you.
So this is a discussion
of the report
from the National Academies
of Science, Engineering,
and Medicine.
And I want to emphasize
this word, Consensus Report.
National Academy reports
have to be based on data.
You can't just give opinions.
You really have to have
data, and it has to be firm,
and you have to be able to
rely on it and stand on it.
So that's sort of the
requirements for a report.
So let me try to push this.
I'm trying to change
the slide, guy.
Now, wait a minute.
I had it upside down.
I think one of the things
I want to start out with
is how did we get into this?
There is a standing committee
at the National Academies
on women in science,
engineering, and medicine.
And that's a standing committee.
They've been in place
for a long time.
And then every once
in a while, they
put a task together
and ask a subcommittee
to take up that task for a
sort of finite period of time.
And so we were tasked by the
National Academies Committee
to do this study.
And we have--
Paula Johnson is the co-chair.
I'm the co-chair.
And there's a list
of our members.
They were social scientists,
they were scientists,
they were engineers, they
were people from industry.
So it was a very,
very broad committee.
This is the statement
of our task.
And just to make
things easy for you,
I've just highlighted the
first three words of each task,
and you can read it if
you read the report.
But we're supposed to
review the research.
We're supposed to examine
existing information,
and we're supposed to identify
and analyze possible policy
strategies and practices.
So that was basically
our task, dealing
with the influence of sexual
harassment in academia
on the career
advancement of women
in scientific, technical,
and medical workforces.
So that was our task.
These were our sponsors.
We had considerable
help from our sponsors.
And we met with our sponsors
at the end of our task.
And I would say their sponsors
were extremely pleased
and want to continue to
move forward in this area.
So I'm going to talk
about the findings.
And then my co-chair Paula will
talk about our recommendations.
First of all, I think it's very
important to get a definition.
I mean, we've heard, in
our opening statements,
several statements
about sexual harassment.
So I think it's
really important.
And I think one of
the important things
that our committee did is give
a very broad definition of this,
which really encompasses
a variety of behaviors.
And so it's really
important to focus on those,
because they really influence
the climate in a university.
I'm focusing on universities.
But it's not just
the universities,
it's the workforce.
It's the entire population.
So we're interested
in gender harassment,
unwanted sexual attention,
and sexual coercion.
Now, obviously,
gender harassment
isn't the most
pervasive of those.
And yet, in some
fundamental sense,
it is almost the most important.
Because it completely
controls the environment
that's seen by women in science,
engineering, and medicine.
So that's really what
we're focusing on.
And so sexual harassing
behavior is considered illegal
when it creates a
hostile environment
or when it is quid pro
quo sexual harassment.
This is one of the
most important figures.
And I'm just going to leave
this up for a little while.
When we hear the word
sexual harassment,
most people focus on the
part of the iceberg that's
out of the water.
And these are clearly
extremely important things
having to do with
physical assault,
having to do with quid
pro quo harassment.
But the part that is
less clear to the public
is the part that's underwater.
And I don't know if
you can all read this
from where you're sitting,
but obscene gestures,
offensive sexual
teasing, insults--
women don't belong
in science, women
don't belong in engineering--
sabotaging women's
equipment, calling people
by vulgar names--
all of those things, in some
sense, are below the waterline.
And yet, in some
fundamental sense,
these are the most
important definitions
of sexual harassment,
and these are the things
that universities really
need to ensure don't happen.
And so that's
really, I think, one
of our very, very important
outcomes of our report
is to really emphasize
these things.
So this is some of
our findings, that
talking about ambient
harassment and gender
harassment, that sexual
harassing behavior can either
be direct, targeted
at an individual,
or it can be ambient.
It can create an unsafe,
uncivil, unwelcome environment.
And when it occurs
severely or frequently,
it can result in the same level
of negative professional and
psychological outcomes,
as can isolated instances
of serious sexual
harassment and coercion.
We believe that sexual
harassment is common,
unfortunately, that it is
common in academic science,
engineering, and medicine,
and that the data--
and we are basing our
report on available data--
the data shows that 50% of women
faculty and staff in academia
experience sexual harassment.
And here, I'm talking about
this very broad definition
of sexual harassment--
an uncivil environment.
And we had extensive
surveys of students.
And this student survey showed
that between 20% and 50%
of students in science,
engineering, and medicine
experience sexual harassment
from faculty or staff.
And this is some data.
I don't know if you
can all see this.
But some of those bars are
40% high, they are 30% high,
they're 20% high.
And they deal with these
various definitions
of sexual harassment-- gender
harassment hostility, gender
harassment crude behavior, and
then unwanted sexual attention
and sexual coercion, which is
obviously the most serious.
And we also looked at these what
I would call intersectionality,
that women of color
experience more harassment--
sexual, racial, or ethnic,
or some combination--
than white women do.
And women of color often
experience sexual harassment
that includes racial harassment.
And sexual and gender
minority people
experience more
sexual harassment
than heterosexual women do.
Another finding is that
this kind of behavior
can impact not only
the individual person,
but it can have an
effect on bystanders,
and it can have an effect on
the entire research enterprise.
And it can undermine women's
professional and educational
attainment, and their
mental and physical health.
It has adverse
effects that affect
not only the targets
of the harassment,
but also the bystanders, the
coworkers, the working groups,
and the entire organization.
And the cumulative effect
of sexual harassment
is significant damage
to research integrity
and a costly loss of talent in
academic sciences, engineering,
and medicine.
Two of the characteristics
that are most associated
with higher rates
of sexual harassment
are, unfortunately,
male-dominated gender ratios
and leadership, and an
organizational climate
that communicates tolerance
of sexual harassment.
So we felt that organizational
climate is by far the greatest
predictor of the occurrence
of sexual harassment,
and ameliorating it
can prevent people
from sexually harassing others.
So what we are
really focusing on
is the creation of a civil,
welcoming, safe environment
for everybody, but particularly
focused on women students,
women faculty.
And I believe that that
is, in some sense, one
of the most important
findings that we have made.
To talk a little bit
about the legal system--
and Anita talked a
little bit about this--
it is not an adequate mechanism
for reducing or preventing
sexual harassment.
We often refer to Title IX as
a platform, not a solution.
Judicial interpretation
of Title IX
has somehow incentivized
organizations
to create policies,
procedures, and training
on sexual harassment that
focuses on symbolic compliance
with current law, which will
help them to avoid liability.
But that's checking the
boxes, and that doesn't really
influence, and it doesn't really
indicate a real commitment
to improve the environment.
So we are focused on
Title IX, Title VII.
And we believe that they
reflect an inaccurate assumption
that the targets of
sexual harassment
will always promptly
report the harassment,
without worrying
about retaliation.
And what we found was the
least common response for women
is to formally report
the harassing experience.
And for many, this is due
to an accurate perception
that they may
experience retaliation
or other negative outcomes
associated with their personal
and professional life.
So in some sense, the
price is higher for them
than it is for the perpetrator.
We also made
recommendations with respect
to the federal government
and professional societies.
Many professional societies
have taken up this issue,
and they have put in place
rules for attending meetings,
and policies and procedures, and
value statements that encourage
a welcome and civil environment
at professional society
meetings.
And there have been quite a
few professional societies
that have done that.
And we believe that they
do have the potential
to be powerful
drivers of change.
And so this is really one of
our most important observations,
is that, really, it's a system
wide change to the culture
and climate in higher education
that is required to prevent
and effectively
address all three
forms of sexual harassment.
So we found that changing the
organizational climate means
creating a climate where
sexual harassment-- again,
this broad definition
of sexual harassment--
where sexual harassment
is not perceived
to be tolerated or permitted.
And you know, I can take
you back to the iceberg
and remind you what all
those little micro things are
that are microinsults that many
people feel are not important.
They are important.
So the characteristics
of an organization
with a permissive climate
towards this kind of behavior,
this kind of sexual harassment,
Include the following--
if there's a perceived
risk to victims
for reporting
harassment, if there
is a lack of sanctions
against offenders,
and if there's a perception
that one's complaints will not
be taken seriously.
These are important pieces of
the organizational climate.
So at this point, I'm going to
stop talking about our findings
and turn the podium over
to my co-chair Paula
Johnson, President
of Wellesley, who's
going to talk about
our recommendations.
[APPLAUSE]
Sheila, thank you so much.
And it is truly a pleasure
to be here with you today.
And I said to Anita, you
know, we started this
before the Me Too
movement started.
And here we are today
with the news still
booming with these issues,
which is truly unfortunate,
but I think points out the
importance of this work.
I want to just recognize
Evelyn Hammond, who
is a member of the
Committee of the National
Academies of Science,
Engineering, and Medicine,
who actually helped to charge
us with doing this report.
So Evelyn, thank you to
you and the committee.
[APPLAUSE]
So I just want to say
a bit about myself.
Before becoming the president
of Wellesley College, I spent--
in July of 2016, I spent 31
years in academic medicine.
I was a professor of medicine
at Harvard Medical School
and a professor of Epidemiology
at the Harvard TH Chan
School of Public Health.
And I did work on
research focused
on the discovery of sex
differences in health
and disease, and
translating that research
into clinical care.
And I do want to
say it has truly
been an honor to serve
on this committee,
with Sheila as my co-chair, and
with Kate Clancy, who's here,
and Frazier Benya, and the
rest of my committee members.
So our report, in terms of its
most important conclusions,
the real focus has been on how
to prevent sexual harassment.
And I just want to
reiterate the point
that Sheila made, that
a system-wide change
in the culture and climate
in higher education
is required to prevent and
effectively address all three
forms of sexual harassment,
sexual coercion,
unwanted sexual attention,
and gender harassment.
And I want to point
out that in spite
of significant attention to
this issue in recent years,
there's absolutely no
evidence to suggest
that current policies,
procedures, and approaches have
resulted in a significant
reduction in sexual harassment.
So it is really time
to really consider
an approach that addresses
the system's cultures
and climates that enable sexual
harassment to perpetuate.
So the top four things
that institutions
can do to prevent
harassment include one,
to integrate values of
diversity, inclusion,
and respect into
policies and procedures.
Number two is to change
the power dynamics
in advisor-trainee
relationships.
Number three, to support
targets of sexual harassment
by providing alternative ways
to access support services,
record information
about an incident,
and report an incident
without fear of retaliation.
And four, to improve
transparency and accountability
to demonstrate that
institutions are investigating
and holding people accountable.
So what I'm going to do is
go through some top-level
recommendations,
and then drill down
on the recommendations
for institutions,
and then drill down on the
recommendations for policy
and federal agencies.
So one, to pay attention to
and enact policies on gender
harassment.
It's important that leaders
and academic institutions,
and research and training sites,
pay increased attention to
and enact policies that
cover gender harassment
as a means of
addressing the most
common form of sexual
harassment and preventing
other types of sexually
harassing behavior.
It is clear that in environments
where gender harassment
is allowed to grow,
allowed to flourish,
that the other forms
of sexual harassment--
unwanted sexual attention,
as well as sexual coercion--
are more likely to occur.
We have to move beyond
legal compliance
to address culture and climate.
Academic institutions,
research, and training sites,
and federal agencies should
move beyond interventions
or policies that represent
basic legal compliance
and that rely solely on formal
reports made by targets.
Three, professional
societies should
accelerate their efforts.
This is an important
area, because we
have seen movement in
professional societies,
and we believe that
they can do more.
Professional societies should
accelerate their efforts
to be viewed as
organizations that
are helping to create
culture changes that reduce
or prevent the occurrence
of sexual harassment.
And last, consider
sexual harassment
equally important as
research misconduct.
Academic institutions
and federal agencies
should consider sexual
harassment equally important
as research misconduct
in terms of its effect
on the integrity of research.
So when we think about
academic institutions,
it's important to-- as we think
about this culture change--
it's important to create
a diverse, inclusive,
and respectful environment.
Now that's easy to say.
But what does that
actually mean?
Academic institutions
and their leaders
should take explicit steps
to achieve greater gender
and racial equity in hiring and
in promotions, and as a result,
improve the representation
of women and a diversity
at every level.
Academic institutions
and their leaders
should take steps to
foster greater cooperation
and respectful work behavior and
professionalism at the staff,
faculty, student,
and trainee levels,
and should evaluate
faculty and staff
on these criteria in
hiring and in promotion.
Academic institutions should
combine anti-harassment efforts
with civility
promotion programs.
And when we say
civility promotion,
we are really talking
about an environment that
fosters a culture of respect.
And as we think about
training, training
should be tailored to
specific population.
One size does not fit all.
This is an area that really
requires more evaluation.
But from the data, it's
clear that training
does need to be tailored
to specific groups--
students and trainees,
staff, faculty,
and those in leadership.
And from the data
that we do have,
it's clear that
training should not
be focused on changing beliefs,
but on changing behavior.
And there are some
qualities of training
that also seem to be associated
with improved outcomes.
Those are one, that
it's in person.
Two, that it's a
reasonable length.
Three, that, again, targeted
to specific audiences.
And four, that leadership
is present and involved
in the training.
It makes a very clear
and strong statement.
Second, it's important to
defuse the hierarchical power
structure in the dependent
relationship between trainees
and faculty, in order to reduce
the risk of sexual harassment.
Now, some of the mechanisms
that academic institutions can
consider include, for
example, mentoring networks,
or committee-based advising,
and really consider
departmental funding, as
opposed to funding only
from one principal investigator,
which only enhances
that dependent relationship.
Next, we also recommend
providing support
for the targets of
sexual harassment.
Academic institutions
should convey
that reporting
sexual harassment is
an honorable and
courageous action.
And I'm going to say that again.
It's an honorable and
courageous action.
Regardless of whether
or not a target
files a formal report,
academic institutions
should provide ways
to access support
services, such as
social services, health
care, legal services, and career
and professional services.
They should also
provide less formal ways
of recording information
about the experience
and reporting the
experience, particularly
if the target is not comfortable
with filing a formal report.
And it's important that academic
institutions develop approaches
to prevent the target from
experiencing or fearing
retaliation in
academic settings.
And this is a critically
important one, and one that,
as Sheila mentioned earlier,
drives women, or drives
targets, not to report.
Next, it's important
to improve transparency
and accountability.
Now, what do we mean by that?
Academic institutions need
to develop and readily
share clear, accessible,
and consistent policies
on sexual harassment and
standards of behavior.
They should include a
range of clearly stated
appropriate and escalating
disciplinary consequences
for perpetrators found to have
violated sexual harassment
policy and/or the law.
Disciplinary action
should correspond
to the severity and
frequency of the harassment.
And the disciplinary
action should not
be something that
is often considered
a benefit for the faculty, such
as reduction in teaching load.
[LAUGHTER]
Or taking time away from campus
service responsibilities.
Decisions regarding
disciplinary actions,
if indicated or
required, should be
made in a fair and
timely way, following
an investigative process
that is fair to all sides.
And academic institutions should
make as transparent as possible
how they're handling reports
of sexual harassment.
Next, we have to strive for
strong and diverse leadership.
College and
university presidents,
myself included, provosts,
deans, department chairs,
and program directors must make
the reduction and prevention
of sexual harassment an
explicit goal of their tenure.
They should publicly state that
the reduction and prevention
of sexual harassment will be
among their highest priorities,
and they should engage
students, faculty, and staff,
and where appropriate, the local
community, in their efforts.
And I do want to say,
President Reif, you
exemplify that leadership.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And lastly, it's
important to make sure
that the entire
academic community is
responsible for reducing and
preventing sexual harassment.
All members of our nation's
colleges and university
campuses, including students,
trainees, faculty, staff,
and administrators,
as well as members
of research and training sites,
should assume responsibility
for promoting civil and
respectful education, training,
and work environments, and
stepping up and confronting
those whose
behaviors and actions
create sexually
harassing environments.
So next, I'm going
to go through some
of the recommendations
for policy
makers and federal agencies.
These include one, better
protecting sexual harassment
claimants from retaliation.
Second, prohibiting
confidentiality
in settlement agreements
that currently enable
harassers to move to
another institution
and conceal past adjudications.
Banning mandatory
arbitration clauses--
which by the fact that
they are arbitration
means that they are private--
banning mandatory arbitration
clauses for discrimination
claims.
Allowing lawsuits to be filed
against alleged harassers
directly, instead
of or in addition
to their academic employers.
Requiring disclosure of
results from surveys.
We should consider
requiring institutions
receiving federal funding
to publicly disclose results
from campus climate
surveys and/or the number
of sexual harassment
reports made to campuses.
We should also
consider requesting
that the National Science
Foundation and the National
Institutes of Health devote
research funds to doing
follow-up analyses on the
topic of sexual harassment
in science, engineering, and
medicine in three to five years
to determine one,
whether research
has shown that the prevalence
of sexual harassment
has decreased.
And second, whether
progress has been
made on implementing
these recommendations.
And third, how and where do
we focus our future efforts.
We also have to attend
to sexual harassment
with at least the same level
of attention and resources
devoted to research misconduct.
They should increase
collaboration
among offices that oversee
the integrity of research--
for example, those
that cover ethics,
research misconduct, diversity,
and harassment issues.
Consider centralizing resources,
information, and expertise,
providing more resources
for handling complaints
and working with targets.
And implementing
sanctions on researchers
found guilty of
sexual harassment.
Require institutions to
report to federal agencies
when individuals
on grants have been
found to have violated
sexual harassment policies
or have been put on
administrative leave
related to sexual harassment.
This is a policy that the
National Science Foundation
has proposed doing.
Agencies should also hold
accountable the perpetrator
and the institution by using a
range of disciplinary actions
that limit the negative effects
on other grant personnel
who were either the target
of the harassing behavior
or innocent bystanders.
And this is a very
important one in terms
of not penalizing the entire
research team, for example.
We should also increase support
for research and evaluation
on the effectiveness of
policies, procedures,
and training on
sexual harassment.
And we should also
reward and incentivize
colleges and universities
for implementing
policies, and programs,
and strategies
that research shows
are more likely to
and are succeeding in
reducing and preventing
sexual harassment.
So those are our
recommendations.
They are pretty broad.
But we think that they are
actionable and can actually
be put into place in some
reasonable period of time.
The National Academies are
actually putting together
a collaborative of
academic institutions
to begin to better understand
what that implementation looks
like and how we
can actually give
feet and legs to this report.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, President Johnson
and Professor Widnall.
Now is the time when we welcome
you to come to the microphones
on either of these
aisles and ask
your questions of the panel.
I will take my seat.
And please don't be shy.
I'm sure many of you
do have questions.
So here are the mics right here.
And I welcome you to come down.
Oh, it's on?
Hi.
So I'm David Singer
from political science.
Thanks so much for being here
and sharing your thoughts
in an incredibly detailed
and thought-provoking study.
I have just a couple of
questions about that.
One is that the
subtitle of your report
is a Consensus Study, which
made me chuckle a little bit.
Because when you get a group
of academics in a room,
it's difficult to
come to consensus.
So I'm curious.
Where were the
dimensions of, maybe,
constructive tension
among all of you
when writing up this report?
My second question is, what
are your recommendations
for when students or faculty
are attending meetings
run by academic
associations that
are off campus and sort of
outside the jurisdiction
of any particular university?
Thanks.
Yeah, why don't I--
does this microphone work?
Yes.
OK.
As I mentioned, the report
is a consensus report.
And the committee
was very diverse.
We had basically
social scientists.
We had engineers and scientists.
We had a few people
from industry.
We had college presidents.
And we spent a lot of time
basically looking at the data,
analyzing the data, trying
to come to consensus.
I won't say there was yelling
and screaming across the table,
but almost.
And ultimately, we
all came to feel
very comfortable with the
report as it was put together.
Those of us who
had certain things
we wanted to see happen--
we were satisfied.
And people who wanted to
say something about the data
and how it should be acquired--
I think they were satisfied.
So I think in the
end, we-- but it
took two years to kind
of come to an agreement.
And I think it was a
very good piece of work.
And I think that's what makes
the report strong is that--
building that consensus.
So do you want to say
something about the other?
I want to just add
to what Sheila just
said, which is that the
foundation of coming
to consensus was evidence.
And at the end of
the day, it is really
the evidence that allowed
us to come to consensus.
We are humans, and so we bring
to the table various opinions
and views.
The question is, are those
opinions and views always
rooted in the best evidence?
And we held ourselves extremely
accountable to that evidence.
And that's why we
feel very strongly
about the reports, the
recommendations-- the findings
and the recommendations.
This isn't opinion.
It's really based on the data.
For the second part of
the question regarding
off-site activity, this is
a critically important area.
And it's why we believe
that field sites
are critically
important, and also
professional organizations.
A lot of the
professional societies
are now taking on this issue and
creating a set of ground rules
for what happens
at their meetings.
So it's really an extension
of the academic institution.
So I think we really need
to view those as a continuum
and really work both at
the institutional level,
but also for the
professional societies.
Can I ask a question
about consensus?
Because you made a
choice about language.
And I think that's
often the hardest
thing to get consensus around.
One of the interesting
language choices that you made
was about the use of
the term civility.
And so I wonder if that
was a point of tension,
or how you came to look
more at using civility
as a sort of broader
category versus harassment,
or some other kinds of phrases
that we might have used--
abuse of power-- to focus on.
You just mentioned--
civility is a positive word.
Harassment is a negative word.
So I think it's a lot easier
to choose the positive word,
civility.
I think it sells better.
Anita, that's a great pickup.
Because we did have
a lot of discussion.
Because I think,
in some arenas, it
can be viewed as a negative--
even though it's
a positive, it can
be viewed as a negative term.
And it can be viewed
as somewhat term
around how are we trying
to guide behavior.
And I think when
we came down to it,
what we're really talking
about here is civility,
meaning a culture
of respect and how
we behave towards each other.
Over here.
Thank you to all the panelists.
My name is Rachel Kurchin,
and I'm a graduate student.
And like, I think,
many PhD students,
I've sort of bounced
around through my time
through many different
funding sources.
And so the point about
departmental funding
as a way to diffuse the sort
of power relationship really
struck me.
And I think that's
something that
would have a lot broader impact
than just diffusing that power
relationship in terms of
people's sense of security
and in terms of their funding
security, not personal safety,
although it's that too.
It strikes me, though, that that
could pose certain challenges
to the way that research
is funded currently
through the granting
agencies in terms
of being granted to a group and
certain number of grad student
years, or something like that.
So I'm curious if the committee
talked about any changes
in the sort of structure
or terms of actual research
grants that might have to
be implemented to make such
a proposal, which I would
be personally really
excited about, kind of
feasible on a large scale,
and not just to
institutions that
sort of might have the
independent funding
to make that happen.
Well, you know, grants--
I agree.
This relationship
between mentor/mentee,
PI/trainee, is so fundamental
to our research structure.
But it also causes some of
the dynamics, as you said,
that are highly problematic.
Research grants are
granted to institutions.
The PI is part of
the institution.
So I'm not saying
that it's easy.
I don't think we
believe it's easy.
We actually didn't talk
about the specifics.
But we felt that given the
money, that the money does
come to institutions,
that there are
ways to begin to
think about some
of the grant money actually
being more centralized
for the grantees when it
is allocated to grantees,
as opposed to being dependent
on that one-to-one relationship.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you so much.
It couldn't be more timely.
My name is Hilary Robinson.
I was a student here.
And I'm a professor
in the law school
and the Department of
Sociology at Northeastern.
I came late, so
forgive me if I'm
going to reference
Catharine MacKinnon
and you already spoke about her.
But it was very notable to me
that the title of this report
is "The Sexual Harassment of
Women," which is very evocative
of MacKinnon's very
influential book, The Sexual
Harassment of Working Women.
And you mentioned, or in several
of your slides, Dr. Johnson,
there was this
reference to the law
and to the need for formal
legality in these kinds
of proceedings, which is what
MacKinnon, who was also a law
professor, called for.
That until we think
about this as a kind
of tort, which is what
the harassment word means,
with all respect to
the idea of civility,
being a kind of nicer way
to get people to engage
in these conversations.
And I just wonder if you
could speak specifically
about your conversations
around the law.
I know, Professor Hill,
you're a law professor.
I think that would be
illuminating for all of us.
Because sometimes
you really do need
to push into the realm of
actual litigation, which
requires money and
institutional support.
Thank you.
Well, I think one of
the things that we're
learning in this moment
is that litigation
has been a necessary but not
sufficient tool for eliminating
the kind of harassment
that we know is prevalent.
We also know that there are some
real limitations to litigation
as a tool--
access to law, access
to legal representation,
is very limited.
The legal system relies on
the most vulnerable people,
very often, to
come and complain.
And we know that there
are high levels--
as much as 60% of people
will experience retaliation.
And we also know that
for low income women,
the amount of pay-off
in terms of wages
often are not high enough
to support the finding
of legal representation.
So those are all of
the things that we're
dealing with-- the
dynamics that we're
dealing with-- that doesn't
make law irrelevant,
but it makes it inadequate.
And I believe that
our recommendations,
the recommendations
of this volume,
as well as
recommendations generally,
are that yes, we need to have
some new legal strategies
around sexual harassment.
But we also need for
work to take place
within institutions that does
not rely on even a complaint
process, or a complaint getting
to the level of something that
is to be litigated,
before we act.
And I think I would not have
chosen the word civility
because I'm a lawyer by
training, so I would--
[LAUGHTER]
But I think it is important
that we change the bar so
that managers
appropriately trained
can intervene before
things get to a level
of a legal violation.
Lawyers don't always work
well with other systems.
But I think we've got
to work together on this
and see this as a holistic,
systemic problem that
will be resolved through a
lot of tactics and approaches.
Thank you.
As you mentioned, your
recommendations and definitions
are pretty broad.
For that very reason,
the Federal Department
of Education, last
year, rescinded
that infamous April 2011 "Dear
Colleagues" letter in order
to better protect the rights
and interests of the accused.
Now, I haven't heard
you say anything
about how you would protect
the rights of the accused,
free speech, and due process.
So you consider those to
be antiquated concepts now.
In my presentation on
the recommendations,
I actually very clearly stated
that processes that were clear
and were fair to all--
both the accused
and the accuser--
should be implemented, and that
there should be transparency
of those, and that
we should also
consider very clear
guidance around what is it
that will result from
certain behavior.
So this is not a black box.
So if that wasn't
clear, I just want
to really make that very clear.
Fair processes are
very important for all.
Thank you.
I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the Senior Vice Provost
for Faculty Development
and Diversity at
Harvard, down the street.
And I want to focus on the
subtitle of your report
and ask a question about
your deliberations--
"Climate, Culture
and Consequences."
And I'll just
abbreviate to academia.
So one of the questions that
I've been having conversations
with people around is the Me
Too movement, this report,
bring to light issues
of sexual harassment,
generally, and also
in the academy.
But we're also concerned about--
perhaps it's the flip word of
civility, but I'll use the word
that's used--
bullying and the concern
that in a lot of our academic
settings-- while there
may be sexual harassment--
and I'm not making light of it--
there is also bullying.
What is it?
Bullying.
Bullying-- both in terms
of trainee and supervisor
relationships, but also
collegial relationships, staff,
and faculty relationships.
I could go on, but I
think you get the context.
Did this come up at all
in your deliberations
as another issue
to take on, which
is related to but different
from the whole question
of sexual harassment?
You're absolutely right, Judy.
And this report
is not meant to be
a full kind of
comprehensive report
on all types of harassment.
We were really focused
on a particular charge
around sexual harassment.
But absolutely, there are
other forms of harassment.
So you're absolutely right.
I think it's another
body of work to be done.
And it's worthwhile, actually,
making another statement.
We were asked very
specifically to look
at sexual harassment in women.
So I want to make very clear
that sexual minorities--
nonconforming people-- actually
experience sexual harassment
at rates that are either
at the same level,
or around the same
level, of women of color,
racial, and ethnic minorities.
So again, this report--
we were given a very specific
charge and focused on that.
But the other areas are
critically important.
Thank you.
Hi.
I am [? Ona ?] [? Hidari. ?]
I am a research fellow at MIT.
But I'm also a journalist.
So my question is going to
be slightly more general
for Ms. Hill.
I've only spent three weeks
in the United States so far.
And the topic of discussion
the past couple of days,
as many of you
know, is something
that relates to what you're
doing, but on a wider scale.
How do you feel that the
conclusions of your report
can be promoted institutions of
higher learning in the United
States if the media scene has--
some certain parts
of the media scene--
have an apologetic
approach towards what
is the recent findings in
relation to Judge Kavanaugh?
And to Ms. Hill, will you be
watching the hearing on Monday
anywhere?
[LAUGHTER]
On Monday, I will be in a
session most of the day,
and not in Washington
in a session.
But I will tune in as I can.
And I guess I'm not quite
clear on your first question.
How can the findings
of this report
be promoted and also
accepted by institutions
of higher learning,
and if there are
certain segments
of the population,
but also especially
the media scene, who
aren't as critical of sexual
harassment as they should be,
as was witnessed in the coverage
of the Kavanaugh hearing.
Well, I think that the
promotion of this report
has already started.
And honestly, one of the
first days that it was out,
I actually talked
to a journalist.
And they were really
pleased with this report,
specifically because it gives
concrete recommendations.
And I think that's going to
be the best way to promote it,
to show that there are concrete
actions that can be taken.
And I don't want to advise
anybody on their promotion.
But I will just say,
leading with the specific
recommendation is, I
think, an effective way
to communicate that
this is serious work
and that it can have
real consequences.
Because that's what
people are ready for.
Hi.
My name is Chen.
And actually, I came here
to speak for another--
I'm the speaker, and
intentionally strategize
so that I could be here.
Because it's an honor
to meet Anita Hill.
But also because I
work on this issue
globally for millennial
womens around the world.
And since this report--
I mean, the person
who was before me--
you said you were charged
with the specific question.
So it answered some
of my question.
But I'm actually concerned
more with the title.
Because globally,
I see this problem.
It is rampant, and it is
unbelievable and unimaginable.
And I really believe we
need to change that title
to "sexual harassment by men."
Because if we are really
talking about accountability,
and we're talking about--
I don't understand why--
to me, by putting "women,"
the onus is on us.
And globally, young
women around the world
are screaming, why
do we keep focusing
on us and not the perpetrator?
[APPLAUSE]
Let me say something about that.
I think it was important
to have a title that
is as broad as possible.
And that's why I do like
the "Climate Culture."
Because it basically
says it isn't
just a few outrageous acts.
It is the entire
climate and culture
that women find themselves in.
So I really felt that we needed
to broaden the task that we
were given, rather than just
focusing on small things.
And I'm just going
to say, the focus
was on sexual harassment
of women, predominantly.
And we say it clearly
in the report,
which is predominantly by men.
I mean, just
technically, that is
what we were asked to focus on.
If you say, sexual
harassment by men,
that can be of women,
which is the majority.
It can be but,
you know, for men.
I mean, so I think it wasn't--
I get your point, and it's
a very important point.
And we do focus in the
report on the issue
that this is predominantly
male on female.
But technically, the title
was really the right title
for the charge we were given.
Hi.
My name is Emily Neal.
I run the Women's and
Gender Studies program here.
And I was curious--
I thought I heard you
say, in the beginning
of your recommendations,
that you specifically
recommended that sexual
harassment training be
done in person.
Is that what you said?
It's one of the recommendations
in the early data.
The data that we
have to date actually
suggests that in-person
training is more effective.
Were there any-- I guess
in terms of that research,
do large institutions
have examples
of doing in-person training
for large populations?
So if this is one of
our recommendations,
actually, that this is
an area, we actually
tried our best to stay away
from recommendations that
said we need further study.
Because there's nothing
like a report that just says
you need to study it more.
But this is an area where there
really is inadequate data.
And the limited data available
does suggest those things
that I stated,
which are in person,
of a particular length,
targeted specifically
towards different groups,
having leadership present
and focused on behavior change,
and not on changing beliefs,
that those were the
characteristics.
But this is really an area
that requires more evaluation
in order to understand,
for example,
in an institution of this size,
what would that look like.
So I think there's
work to be done.
Thanks.
And thanks for the op-ed today.
Hi.
First of all, thank you all.
My name is Melinda Deramo.
And I was just
wondering if you would
have advice for
something, like something
I could do, to get visibility
into an institution,
a laboratory--
I work for a laboratory--
4,000 people, 13% women.
And just visibility into the
harassment cases, numbers.
And the organization
is very adamant
that it should be handled only
on a case-by-case basis, where
there's just no awareness.
Anything-- advice,
like anything I
could lean on to
try to get a survey,
or like when that's not allowed?
I assume from what you say
that you're a graduate student.
Is that correct?
No.
I work.
Oh, you work.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess what I would recommend--
I was a graduate student.
I have been very impressed
with the Association
of Women Graduate Students
and the Association
of Undergraduates.
And I think various
groups can form.
People can sort of form
groups, and join, and discuss.
And that group
becomes supportive,
and it becomes effective.
And you can move
the issue along.
And it gets the people involved,
and they will learn more.
So I would recommend
forming some groups,
and talking about it, and trying
to move the ball down the road.
We have been.
Yeah.
OK, thanks.
Hi, I'm Mike Bono.
And I'm a post-doc here.
And I want to thank you all
for coming and presenting.
So my question is, I remember
when I was in grad school,
there was this clear and
pervasive message of, if you
crossed a professor
directly-- whether it was
your advisor, or
another professor,
or you were the
victim of harassment,
or you were just a
bystander-- that you
crossed a professor directly,
they would ruin your career.
And I think that we have
this challenge in academia,
in particular with this
idea of a good word
from the right person
can make your career
and a bad word can break it.
So my question is, as
researchers, and as
a research community, how
can we change this culture
to make it easier for
people to come forward
in cases of harassment?
Well, I mean, this
is at the heart
of some of the
recommendations, which
is the fear of retaliation.
And until we really begin
to change the culture,
this is not going
to be a one by each.
Because that's not
the way to change it.
And that actually has
been our approach.
We get a bad actor and a person
who has violated the policy.
And then, OK, we deal with that.
And then it's over
until the next one.
So it's really not until
the culture changes.
I'm not saying you don't
have to do those things.
But it's not really until
the culture changes that we
begin to change the behavior.
And this issue about the fear
of retaliation is a real one.
And I think that that's one
that, again, from the very top,
all the way down to
colleagues-- and it's
going to take
colleague-to-colleague pressure
as well, and responsibility.
And that's the
way I really think
we're going to begin to change
the culture so that there isn't
this fear.
And to think about, again,
diffusing that power
relationship, which is when
you are fully dependent
on one person--
and you know, that can
be either in a class,
obviously that's one
way, but usually it's
in a research environment--
that can be highly problematic.
So who are the others around
you in some network of mentors
that you can rely on to help
in these situations, as well
as the institution.
Just form a community.
Talk to other professors,
talk to other students.
Go to the department head.
Share information with people
who, in a fundamental way,
share your values.
But I have to say, I really
do understand your question.
Because I've been on
committees, hiring committees,
and we get letters
of recommendation.
And we look at the letters,
and we say, oh, this person
studied with x.
Why isn't there a letter
from x in the file?
And retaliation can be overt.
It can be covert.
And so what we have to do is
not only question the power
or diffuse it, but we've
got to question our systems
for evaluating people
for jobs, whether or not
we are opening up
the door, really,
for this kind of behavior
that allows for, or enables,
those kinds of power abuses.
And so I think that it's
more than just burden
on the students.
We have to think about
how the dynamics work
and whether or not, in our
hiring processes and decisions,
we are contributing to it.
And I do think that the
leadership can be very helpful.
And by no means--
I agree with you, Anita--
this is not the
job of the student.
It is the job of leadership
and leadership at all levels.
And this point about
how we make decisions
is critically important,
in addition to, again,
getting to when we're hiring--
this idea of the way
that we protect harassers
with various confidentiality
agreements, again,
and how we pass people from
institution to institution.
We really do have to stop.
Hi.
My name's Kara.
I'm a graduate student.
And thank you guys so much.
So the report-- in what you
talked about today, there's
a lot of discussion about
diagnosing the problem
and recommendations
for fixing the problem.
But to me, a lot
of it feels reliant
on getting people to
care in the first place
and want to participate
in these things.
So I mean, just
like two examples.
At the highest
levels, I think a lot
of people in this
room probably, maybe,
saw the documentary on Netflix.
I hope this is the right name.
It's called Hunting
Ground, which
I think was really
shocking, that
showed kind of
the extreme levels
that universities go to to
cover these-- you know, in some
of these more severe
sexual assault cases,
so that they don't
ever get to light.
And then on the lowest level,
on a peer-to-peer level,
I think there's like a lot
of women in this room--
probably more women
than men it seems like--
and I don't think
women outnumber
men in this university.
And I think with my own
personal experiences,
I'm involved in a lot
of personal things
with trying to
start, you know, more
at grass roots or whatever,
movements to support women,
but also support
students in general.
And it seems like in my
experience with that,
it's also women-dominated.
So how do you get
people, my peers,
that are men at
the lowest levels,
and how do you get universities
at the highest levels
to care about this, and where
does that fit into this report?
So I'm going to begin by
the highest levels, which
is part of what we are doing
with this report is really
focusing on the highest
level university, college
presidents and others
in positions of power.
How do we get this
word out to them?
And then, how do we get them to
start working with each other?
Because there's nothing
like peer pressure.
This has really got to
come from those in power.
It's not the responsibility--
I mean, obviously, at the lowest
level, there's work to be done.
But we have got to get
the highest level engaged.
The organizations that
need to be engaged.
I don't know how many people
saw that the triple AS--
Peggy Hamburg is the
president-- they just
announced that they will
actually take action
to remove members who have
been found in violation
of sexual harassment policies.
And the National Academies
of Science. engineering,
and Medicine are
looking at this as well.
I think that this is
the kind of change
that we really need
to begin seeing.
Francis Collins came out with
a statement, either yesterday
or two days ago, about
harassment at the NIH.
It's a good statement--
not strong enough.
But it's a step in
the right direction.
So I think there is the
National Science Foundation
and what it plans.
There's got to be a movement at
the top around changing the way
we do business to make
some of the things
that you are discussing--
quite frankly, not only are
they illegal to, you know,
cover up that kind of action,
but just generally not done
in institutions.
Hi.
My name's Elizabeth Burr.
I'm one of the
undergrads here at MIT.
And I believe what you guys
said about protecting people
from retaliation, or removing
the fear of retaliation,
would make a
phenomenal difference.
Did you guys put--
or what thought or
ideas did you have
about protecting people
in such a social media
heavy environment?
So one, it's a very good point.
And I may not answer
your question directly.
But I want to give you
an example of where
it's very clear women
do fear retaliation
and often will not report.
What mechanisms can
we use to actually get
women to identify the
instances of harassment that
have occurred, without actually
coming forward until they
are ready to come forward?
So there, for example, is
a program called Callisto.
And it was started
out on the west coast.
Now a number of colleges
and universities use it.
And what it is, it's
the reporting system
that allows a target to go
in and actually time stamp
and identify an incident--
and can do it anonymously.
And you can actually
have access to data
to understand whether or not
there are others reporting.
And it is there in
the record so that,
and until you are ready
to actually report.
So it's a way of identifying,
allowing you to kind of see
what else is happening.
But that's a way, that's
one way, of allowing women
to record data without
going that next step,
again, until you're ready.
And you know, it's not perfect.
But it's actually been
adopted by a number of places
and is having
significant success.
So that's just one example.
Hi, my name is
[? Sara Silverland. ?]
And I'm a grad student.
And my question, you've
talked a lot about what you
can do to change the culture.
But what happens when
someone does come forward,
and how can the community
best support them
when that does happen?
And that's sort of
relevant to me this
me because I went to
the same high school
as Christine Blasey Ford.
And our alumni network has
been reeling and signing
letters of support around this.
And so how should we
best deal with that?
Well, the first thing
I would say is, one,
and I think I began with this--
reporting is an act of courage.
And we should support
those who report.
That's the first thing.
Second, if there are
incidents of sexual harassment
in which the target
does not want
to be public with reporting
but goes to a person
to share the information, is
not ready to come forward,
then we really have to be pretty
active in providing support,
whether or not that person
wants to be public in reporting.
And there are a
series of supports
that have to do with
mental health, health care,
social services, et cetera.
So I think that
there are a number
of ways that we need to both
honor and support targets
of harassment.
Hi, I'm Nick Rothbacher,
and I'm a grad student here.
A lot of the recommendations
that you make in the room
or require a
significant commitment
from the institutions
to challenge themselves
and do a lot of
things that would seem
to be against the current
interests of the institution,
like damaging their image,
or sanctioning members
of the research community.
How do you propose that we
enforce these recommendations
against institutions that
often have more power than--
than I can describe
in this time?
Yeah, I mean, I could
sort of take that on.
I mean, when we got to
the point in the report
where we sort of understood
what the findings were,
we sort of sat back and said,
OK, what's the solution.
And the first word that
comes to mind is leadership.
And you have to start there.
You have to start
with leadership,
with a commitment on the part
of leadership to the values
that we have laid out.
And so you're talking
presidents, provosts--
[LAUGHS]-- I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding, Marty--
deans, department heads.
People who are leaders in the
community that share common
values, and they can make
those values more public
and then the rest
of the community
will gain confidence
that this is
an institution that values
the values that we've
been talking about.
And so that's really
where we started.
And then we got quite specific.
OK, what should fellow
federal agencies do?
Well, what about the law, and
all these other things, but it
all began with the whole
question of leadership.
And I think that's probably
where the recommendations
begin, is the responsibility
of academic institutions
to have a safe, welcoming,
civil environment to support
students.
And everything else
below that are specifics
that one needs to work out.
But I mean, it
really starts there.
So I just want to add one thing
because the question becomes,
so who holds the leader,
the top leader accountable?
Well, you know,
we do have bosses?
And they're called
boards of trustees.
At MIT, you have an
executive committee.
And, you know, those
people also have
to be held responsible
because then they hold
the leadership responsible.
These are issues that need
to be discussed and reported
on openly, transparently, and
so it isn't just the leader.
The leader reports
to somebody, and we
need to also be talking to that
level of leadership-- which
really has kind of
the ultimate power.
Yeah, and I would agree.
And in an ideal world,
that would work.
[LAUGHTER]
But very often we know
that the bosses of the boss
are more conservative
about these issues,
and more protective of the
institutional reputation,
than even is the president.
And so you have to look
at external levers.
In the last few years, it's
been the Department of Education
that has pushed the levers.
[LAUGHTER]
Not so much anymore.
But there are alums.
I mean, alums now
have significant power
to influence--
the changes, yes,
you know, right?
To initiate and
instigate changes.
And maybe not change
the minds or the values,
but to reinforce the work
that the leaders are trying
to take on and may
be getting pushback
from different sources.
So I think that there
are a number of ways.
But on another level,
you have to convince
institutional leaders that
it is in their best interests
to address these problems
in this moment, in the world
today, because
institutional reputation can
be lost by one lawsuit that
reveals what is happening.
And if a lawsuit happens, all
kinds of discovery can happen.
And so it is no
longer tenable to say
that you're protecting yourself
by not being transparent.
And at the very
heart of this report,
really, is a call
for transparency.
So I think a lot of things need
to come together to be sure.
And you know, the other thing
that you have is students.
Students can protest.
Students can make noise.
And believe me, they
make more of a difference
than I think they
sometimes think they have.
And one other, I just wanted to
add one more lever because, I
think, Anita, that
was, I mean, it's
a very important
statement, which
is that is exactly why we made
the recommendations on funders.
If you really want a lever under
funders, your research funding,
is a critical one.
So that's another aspect of it.
So we have two more
people at the mics.
And we're going to take
these two questions,
and then we're going
to be able to wrap up,
Thanks again for the talk.
One thing that struck me in
the presentation was that--
I think someone briefly
mentioned that institutions
have tried to implement policies
that reduce sexual harassment,
but there is no statistically
significant decrease
in sexual harassment.
So how can we be sure that
institutions will ever
get policies that are
actually meaningful,
and not just checking the boxes
like they did in the past?
Well that's the whole--
I mean you're at the heart of
what we're attempting to do,
which is that a lot of
the approach in the past
has been one that has been
purely legalistic, avoiding
risk, checking the boxes.
And that really
does not do anything
for changing the culture
and changing behavior.
And we have the data
to support that.
So I think this
really is about kind
of moving away
from that mentality
to a more
comprehensive approach.
Hello, my name is Ashley Blum.
I'm a grad student over
in the business school.
I wanted to thank you
all for taking the time
to share your thoughts today.
I also want to
take an opportunity
to thank everyone here for all
of their questions and insight.
If I'm understanding kind of
the trends of this, what I feel
is that we're all struggling
with kind of the rubber
meeting the road.
We have all these
great ideas, but it's
difficult to get
them implemented.
And so one of the things that
I actually wanted to offer
was, in the spirit of
students making noise,
a bit of a solution here.
And so, at the
business school, I
am part of a group
called Breaking the Mold.
And in February, we're
hosting a hack for inclusion.
And so this is
geared towards trying
to combat bias in our schools,
communities, and in our jobs.
So we are looking for
broader involvement
within the academic
community, and also
the Boston surrounding areas.
So if you're interested,
please take a look
at our web site which,
is Breaking the Mold MIT.
And let us know.
So thank you again for
your time, I appreciate it.
That's a great way to end.
Good way to end.
[APPLAUSE]
So I just wanted to wrap up
by saying thank you to Sheila,
to Anita, and Paula,
for leading this really
thoughtful, insightful,
and I would even
say, hopeful discussion.
You are demonstrating
the kind of leadership
that your report calls for.
That is so essential to
eradicating sexual harassment
in academia.
So through your
hard work, you are
offering all of higher
ed, very importantly,
an actionable roadmap to follow.
And also a call to
action to answer.
We're really grateful
for your example,
and for your dedication.
And to the audience--
thank you so much for
caring about these issues,
for engaging with us, and for
being committed to finding
the solutions we urgently need.
At the end of the
day, every one of us--
and we heard this
today-- has a role
to play in contributing
to the cultural changes
that this report calls for.
By being here today you're
sending a clear message
that, together, we can
make things better.
So thank you for sharing this
responsibility with all of us
here at MIT and across
higher education.
And thank you, again, for taking
part in this vital discussion.